[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting episode of a unl's
podcast in today's episode we're deling
into te mental health in high school the
factors contributing on mental health
issues and ways to promote mental
well-being whether you're a student a
parent a an educator or simply
interested in understanding the Dynamics
of mental health in high school this
episode has something for you so without
further Ado let's jump into our
topic mental health in high school is
quite critical and often
overlooked high school students face a
unique set of academic social and
personal challenges that can
significantly impact their mental
health I believe that the main source of
mental health problems in schools is the
stress and pressure that High School
comes
with personally I have put myself in a
toxic relationship with
stress I need the stress of worrying
about every small detail in order to
function or finish something properly I
find that it keeps me on my feet and
prepared at all times but not all people
can function with it the way I do
sometimes even I can feel drained but
you need to find a balance in order to
use stress for your own good and not let
it consume you teachers should also
encourage a balanced approach to
academics to reduce
stress the pressure in high school can
also be a significant Factor
contributing to mental health issues
along
students high school students start to
feel the looming pressure of college and
future careers and combined with the
stress of assignments and grades that
just bombs a young teenage
mind peer pressure is also a huge Factor
on an individual's mental
well-being the desire to fit in to
conform to so social norms can lead to
anxiety depression and other mental
health
issues it's essential to develop strong
coping skills self-esteem and a
supportive network of friends and family
to resist negative peer pressure and
maintain good mental
health
bullying can also have a negative effect
on the mental health of students it can
easily lead to persistent feelings of
fear sadness and hopelessness leading to
anxiety and
depression bullying also wears away a
student
self-esteem and selfworth and affect
their confidence and
self-image victims May isolate
themselves to avoid bullies leading two
feelings of loneliness and social
withdrawal this is why I believe that
Anonymous reporting systems are crucial
in a social and learning environment it
encourages students to report bull
bullying instance without the fear of
retaliation while Gathering some
information about this episode I came
across a very interesting tedex speech
by Haley hardcast
Haley suggested that parents should
allow their children once in a while a
mental heal day off from
school they will be treated as if they
had the flu or weren't feeling
physically well the school would keep
Taps on the students with enough mental
health B and actually inform ones with
less so my dad has literally been doing
this for the past five years without me
and probably him even
realizing we just we just thought about
having a fun day of from school we would
treat ourselves with a well-deserved and
fancier than usual breakfast we would go
shopping or maybe catch a movie or even
just relax at home and honestly it's a
win-win my dad gets to spend the day
with me on the other end I feel relaxed
I feel refreshed and ready to deal with
the struggles and the drama of high
school I believe that for students with
mental health issues often times
stepping forward and asking for help is
the hardest step but being provided the
help and attention would be a huge
milestone for their road to mental
well-being I also believe that schools
should feel like safe places counseling
services in high schools are vital for
promoting students mental
wellbeing they should provide
professional counselors who are trained
and licensed for counseling sessions
they should ensure confidentiality to
create a safe space for students to open
up teachers should identify and address
mental health concerns in students as
early as possible to prevent
escalation they should also assess the
effectiveness of the counseling services
to make room for
improvements there should be classes
that would teach students about mental
health to avoid online self- diagnosing
to reduce stigma and to teach the
importance of seeking for help and
not feeling ashamed of
it to wrap this up
I think it's uh vital to create a
supportive and empathetic environment
where students develop a healthy mental
state there are we are in a very
important stage in our life where we are
shaping our future
selves so there are lots of different
ways to fight mental health problems in
high schools and to raise awareness of
mental
well-being but the most important thing
is just making an effort for that person
and mainly just being there so that was
all I prepared for this episode it was
definitely a very fun and enlightening
top topic for my listeners in high
school I wish everyone a fun safe and
Unforgettable Journey hope you've
enjoyed this episode and
[Music]
bye